word problems based on age are pretty
common in competitive exams look at this
one gaurav's mother is 28 years older
than him and then we have been given a
condition which was true five years ago
and we have been asked to find that
present age okay there are two entities
here Gaurav and his mother leaving some
space here we draw a column to write
their present age the reason why we left
some space here is because we have been
given a condition which was true five
years ago a condition in the past
generally when you draw a time line you
have the pass towards the left of the
present so this positioning of columns
makes it slightly easier to
conceptualize the problem let's say
gaurav's current age is X years and
gaurav's mother is 28 years older than
him
the word is tells us that the condition
is mentioned for the present ages
so if Gaurav is X years old his mother
will be x plus 28 years old that
satisfies the condition for the present
age Gaurav X years and his mother x plus
28 years old what will be the age five
years ago if God offers X years old
today his age five years ago would have
been X minus five years and his mother's
age would have been X plus twenty eight
minus five years that was simple we have
the current age as well as the age five
years ago the condition says that five
years ago gaurav's mother was five times
as old as he was mother's age five years
ago was X plus 28 minus five and
gaurav's age five years ago was X minus
five so this will equal five times X
minus 5 this is the condition for the
past solving this we get the value of x
as 12 we are asked for the present age
gaurav's present age is x
so gaurav's current ages 12 years and
his mother's age will be 12 plus 28
which is 40 years that's our answer
now let me ask your sub question related
to this example what would be their age
10 years hence that's where the third
column of future age would come in 10
years later gaurav's age would be X plus
10 and his mother's age would be X plus
28 plus 10 it would be 22 and 50 years
respectively and this column would have
helped us more if we were given the
condition for future age